Wow,
there was one very important thing that
had happened to me when I was 16 years
old,
even though I was the popular kid in my
school.
They voted me for two years in a row,
the chairman of the programming
committee,
which means I ran student assemblies
five days a week and I program to a
week.
Um,
so I was the emcee for these things.
And one day the Jews.
Did you manage that and simultaneously
be unpopular?
Uh,
that's a good question.
I think my school had very school was
school,
was founded by an Acolyte of John Dewey
and he was behind the scenes actually
setting the school law and it,
you know,
schools have their popularity positions,
president,
vice president,
secretary,
treasurer,
all of that.
But my school was clever enough to start
putting functional team committees
together.
In your very first days at school,
your very first day,
a,
were a freshman year.
Now when you,
when you have kids vote for president
and vice president or an vote for the
most popular kid in the school as the
precedent.
The second most popular kid as vice
president,
the most popular girl as secretary and
the most popular Jewish treasurer.
That's just the way it goes.
Um,
so I was never aligned for any of those
positions.
I had no popularity whatsoever.
In fact,
one of my classmates actually fired with
remarkable accuracy from only 23 d way a
soccer ball directly into my face.
And believe me,
it has a lot of force distance of 20
feet.
So,
but when it comes to functional
positions,
like how do we run these school
assemblies?
The popular kids don't have a clue.
So if you bring them into a room,
if there arbitrarily,
for example,
assigned to a committee,
um,
they will all piss on there a little
piece of territory.
They'll all stake out a position of some
kind just to establish their status in
the room.
And after 15 minutes.
So this one,
they've all said their piece and it
comes time to actually do something.
They are clueless,
they're silent,
they don't know what to do.
And if there is an unpopular geek like
me,
who at that 20 minute mark all of a
sudden has an idea,
they will glom around you even if they
don't like you.
Right?
So.
So yeah.
So competence can,
can,
can step in where we're popularity
cannot go.
Yes.
That's a very well put phrase.
So,
so there I was the head of this
programming committee and one of the
kid,
one of the juniors came to me and said
we're doing a dance.
We're,
you know,
we're setting up a dance and could you
advertise it for us?
And he didn't realize just how absurd
that statement was.
If there's a dance or a party of any
kind in buffalo,
New York,
one of the first things you have to
realize about it is I am not just
disinvited.
I haven't invited to stay as far away as
humanly possible and yet they want me to
advertise this dance.
So Jordan,
I can't dance.
I am,
I can't do a box step.
I can't do a Fox trot,
I can't do a waltz,
I can't do any of those things.
But I went onstage and put some music on
the turntable and danced,
and I saw the pupils dilating of the
audience.
Three hundred 50 people who hated me and
hated me for two and a half years.
At that point,
their pupils were dilating,
their faces were melting.
I felt that pseudopod at vantage coming
to me and through me as if I were a
pipe.
I felt it going up to something inside
of me more or less.
It had level that utterly transmogrified
it and I felt the energy being sent back
through every move that I was making an
I had an outer body experience.
I saw,
I thought I was on the ceiling.
I've watched all of this from the
ceiling and it apparently it looked like
a loony toon drawn on Lsd as if Chuck
Jones had been doing Tom and Jerry after
taking a very big hit of acid.
It was one of the strangest,
weirdest things you've ever seen and
when it was all over.
So that was my ecstatic experience.
When it was all over,
the audience did something.
It had never done in my days at school,
I would never do again,
so long as I was there,
it surged to the foot of the stage and
as if it had practice this act all its
life,
it picked me up off the stage,
it put me on his shoulders,
it carried me out of the auditorium and
it carried me up the pathway to the
building above where we had our classes.
So that was my introduction.
Yeah.
And,
but this is a crazy story,
right?
And this is three years after I'd gone
off after the ecstatic experience
knowing that it was something vital.
I mean,
I'd heard at the age of 14,
two years earlier,
I had heard that there was a book called
the varieties of religious experience.
And in those days we had no Amazon.
We had local bookstores and local
bookstores in Buffalo.
I mean,
give me a break.
Um,
but I finally found a copy at the
University of Buffalo Bookstore and it
felt as if William James had been laying
out a series of examples of the ecstatic
experience with all of its delusions and
hallucinations.
And all the rest on the laboratory bench
and then saying to me,
look,
you're coming along,
70 years later you're going to have
scientific tools that I did not have.
This is your job.
And it was my job,
not just because William James was
giving it to me because something deep
inside of him he was crying out to
understand it.
And it probably was that the privilege
of social disconnection,
the privilege of social deprivation,
because that privilege made me sensitive
and it's always made me sensitive to
group behavior.
So when I was in Moscow in 2005
lecturing a group of quantum physicists
from all over the world on why
everything you know about quantum
physics does wrong.
It's because there is no such thing as
an isolated particle.
Every particle is part of our herd,
a mob,
a group of some kind.
Um,
the,
a lot of quantum physicists on the idea
that when you,
when you treat a Photon,
a single photon in a certain way,
when you split it into here's how it's
going to be,
hey,
but if it's being measured,
that's not going to happen.
Well,
guess what,
we're constantly taking each other's
measure.
Photons are constantly taking each
other's measure because they move in
groups,
crowds and herds.
That's why a beam of sunshine comes
through your window,
not a photon of sunshine.
And when I finished the speech,
I was sure they were gonna throw me out
of the conference because these are all
people committed deeply to quantum
physics and instead they sat there
beaming like a proud uncles and I could
not figure out why.
And three years later my collaborator in
quantum physics at the university at the
[inaudible] Institute of Applied
Mathematics,
so the Russian Academy of Sciences in
Moscow Senate email and he said,
Dr,
use your club who ran that conference
and gave you such a hard time about your
credit card.
Has just published a book.
It's a new approach to quantum physics.
It's called constructive of physics.
You have to get it immediately.
So I downloaded it from arcserve org.
I listened to it that afternoon on my
hour and a half walk through the park on
my way to the cafe where I do all my
work and I got all excited.
Every social concept.
That means every concept that I had
given in this talk was in this book.
So Jordan,
I've had the privilege of proceedings
through life with this enormous
advantage social deprivation.